[音楽]
[拍手]
偉大な指揮者であっても
駆け出しの指揮者であっても
等しく同じことというのがあります
それは
指揮者は一人では何もできないということ
です
ここに指揮棒がありますこれを振っても何
の音も出ない
これを投げても
カラカラという音しかしない
指揮者が指揮者であるためには
絶対的に
他者との共振というものを必要とします
指揮者の
仕事の2つそれは一つはですね
リハーサルというところにあります
リハーサルというのは
指揮者の頭の中にあるものを
実現していく
仕事ですねその時それがなぜ成り立つかと
いうと
引いてくださる奏者がいてそしてそうした
一人一人の一人一人の頭の中にある音楽
人生
背負ってきたものそれらと
科学反応が起きて一つの上に
向けて
進んでいくわけです
じゃあ本番はどうなのか
皆さんがいつも見てくださるものは本番な
わけですけれども
本番は
リハーサルを重ねたその先にある
賭けのようなものなんですね
決して私たちは
リハーサルで
作り上げたものそのままお見せしている
わけではありません
あっため直して出すようなことではなくて
本番というのはその場で一からクッキング
するようなそういう営みなんですね
その時私たちは大いに
空間と時間を共有する人たちに
影響されています
今私が話している時でもそうですここで皆
さんは聞いてくださっています
それはただ聞いてくださっているだけでは
なくてここに参加してくださっている
私たちは
演奏するときにこの場というものを共有し
たお客さんたちそしてスタッフの方々そう
いう方々の
集中力であったりエネルギーであったり
そういうものに大きく影響されています
この中でしばらく音楽家というのは
無観客公演というものが続きました
今
改めてお客さんたちともにしてですね
演奏できるようになったとき
真っ先に感じるのはどれほど私たちがお客
さん一緒に場を共有する人たちに影響され
ていたかということでした
今
リハーサルと本番の話をしました
リハーサルでは
演奏者と
本番では
場を
共にしてくださる皆さんとここで何が起き
ているのか
それを一言で言うには私はこの
レゾナンス
共振この言葉が一番ぴったりくるように
思います
指揮者は何を指揮しているのかそれはただ
の音楽を指揮しているのではないんです
指揮者は
集った人々のエネルギーを意識している
ゆえに指揮者は振ると言いますけれども
フルというよりは
共に振るまさにこの共振という言葉が
ぴったり来るんじゃないかなと思います
そしてこれはこの共振ということは私が
人生をかけて追い求めたい哲学のような
ものであって
一言で言えば
指揮者の仕事は共振を起こすこと
そして
良い演奏とは何か聞かれると私はいつも
激しい共振が起きることだというふうに
答えているんですね
じゃあ
激しい共振っていうのはどうやったら
生まれるのか
要はそのことを少しだけお話したいと思い
ます
今リハーサルと本番の話をしました
皆さんが
主に指揮者にというものを見てくださるの
はこのリハーサルと本番が主だと思うん
ですけれどもその前には
準備という時間がありますこれは決して
皆さんの目に触れない大変に孤独な時間
です
最初に
指揮者というのは
他者を絶対的に必要とするというふうに
言いましたけれども
共振強い共振を生む根源は
実のところこの準備の段階にかかっている
と私は思う
じゃあ準備っていうのはどういうものなの
か
ピアニストならたくさんたくさんピアノに
向かって演奏するでしょう
バイオリニストならここで
ひたすら
練習するでしょう
ところが最初にお伝えしたように
指揮者は一人では何もできない
オーケストラの楽譜
もちろんここを
準備の段階で一生懸命自分でピアノで弾い
てみたり
歌ってみたりそういうことはできます
ですが
準備の段階から
オーケストラそのもの
お願いして
演奏してもらって
準備を救っていくそんなことはできないん
です
したがって我々は
楽譜一冊を机に置き
その楽譜
必殺と
徹底的に向き合うということしかできない
なぜなら
楽譜を再現すれば音楽になるというもので
はないからです
楽譜に書かれているものは
あくまで
恒例音楽まだ設計図の段階の音楽であって
これをどういうふうに立ち上げていくかと
いうところが私たちの
主な仕事なんですね
ちょっと例を見せた方がわかりやすいかな
と思いますので
楽譜を映しましょう
これは私が大学時代に
勉強の時に使っていた
ベートーベンの
第九
合唱が付いているあの曲ですねそれの
スコアですちょっと
汚い字すぎてですねここでお見せするのが
恥ずかしかったんですけれどもまあこれも
また自分らしいと思ってお見せしています
ここには無数の音符がありますそして
ピアノであったり
フォルテであったりたくさんの指示があり
ます
これを演奏したとしてもどういうふうに
演奏するかっていうところはかなりの余地
があるわけです
例えば
ピアノ一般的には小さく
これ一つとってもどれぐらい小さくなのか
何デシベルか書いてないんですよ
あくまでもピアノというのは小さくという
のはその他との相対的なバランスで小ささ
が決まってくる
どれぐらいのバランスなのかということは
楽譜には書ききれていないことなのでそれ
を我々は
徹底的に見て考えていくわけです
例えばですけれどもこの最初この大工と
いう音楽はですね
ピアノ2つ
ピアニッシュもとても小さくというところ
で
ホルンガを
鳴らすんですね
そのホルンのピアノ2つというのが
一体どういうピアノ2つなのか
もしかするとそのピアノ2つは
これから爆発の予兆をはらんだものすごく
緊張感のあるピアノ2つかもしれない
あるいは
暴爆とした宇宙に
行ってんだけポンと明かりが灯るような
ピアノ2つかもしれない
そのことを
イマジネーションを膨らませながら
徹底的に考えていくというのが
指揮者の強みと
準備と言われるものなんですね
本当は
作曲者に聞けば
早いんです
でも
ベートーヴェンがとっくに亡くなって
しまっていますし
我々が演奏する作曲家というのはみんな
天国に行ってしまっているだから聞きよう
がない
故にまずは楽譜に向き合ってこの曲がどう
いうハーモニーでどういう構造で
ベートーヴェンだったらどういう社会に
生きて
誰と仲良くて何を食べ
誰と恋しそして誰と戦ってそういう客観的
な事実を
リサーチをどんどんどんどん重ねていく
わけです
しかし
決定的に重要なのは
この客観的な事実を積み重ねたその先に
この
作品は
君にとって何であるのかということを
言えるようになるということだと思います
つまり
客観を突き詰めたその先に
自分の主観と
矛盾なく合流できるかどうか
なぜなら
指揮者
指揮しますけれどもその作品の多くはもう
何万回と演奏された作品です
例えば運命ベートーベンの運命でも何でも
いいですもうおそらく何億と演奏されてる
でしょうそして偉大な巨匠の演奏も
たくさん残っています
その演奏を真似するなら意味はないし
真似するということも簡単にはできないし
真似するんだったら自分がやる必要はない
つまり式題に上がるという時には
君にとってこの作品が何であるのか
君にとってこの1音が何であるのかこれに
答えられない限りは私たちは好き嫌いに
上がれない
そういうことをしているのだと思います
このことを私はいつも自分の準備の
バロメーターとして一つの言葉で言い表し
ています
それは
君でなければならないのか
今この作品を演奏するのが自分でなければ
ならないのか
このことに対してイエスと言えるまで
徹底的にここに下げるわけです
そして面白いのがこの君でなければ言え
ないいけないのかということを言えるよう
になった瞬間というのはどこか
作品と
作品
作品が持っている問いそのものと自分が
共振できた感覚になるんです
客観的な事実を積み重ねたその先に主幹が
響き合うその時
君でなければならない自分でしかできない
ものがある思える時があるまるで
作曲者が自分になり自分が作曲者になって
化身になったような感覚になれる時がある
んです
その次元まで準備するということが我々に
は多分一番大事なんだと思います
最初に
準備が大事しかし一人で
何もできないということを言いました
我々は結局のところを何も一人ではでき
ないかもしれないけれども
ずっと深くまで入っていって君でなければ
ならないのかという問いに答えれる次元
までやらなければいけないそのためには
絶対的に孤独が必要です
一人で降り立ち一人でその真理に
たどり着こうとするような時間が必要で
あるということは私は強く言いたいと思い
ます
なぜなら指揮者は何も一人ではできない
から思ったものを誰かに伝えて始めて
できるわけですよねこれは指揮者だけじゃ
なくて
よく言う世界を変えるには自分や足元から
だという言葉とも響き合っているものだと
思います
何か強い共振を思うと思ったらまずは
自分が力強く震えていなければいけない
そして
孤独という問題と
逃げず向き合い
君でなければならないのかという問いに
答えられるまで
値引き上げなければいけない
何でもいいんですその
自分でなければいけないと思えるものは
例えばある問題に対して本当に面白いと
思える
面白いと思ったものっていうのは伝えたく
なるじゃないですか
で伝えたものが面白かったらそれを聞いた
人は
他の人に伝えようと思うじゃないですか
そういうムーブメントを埋めるようになる
ためにはやっぱり自分の中で強く震えて
いるということが
絶対的に必要なんだと思います
こういうお話をすると私はいつも
自分の学生時代の師匠の一人である
立花孝志というジャーナリストのことを
思い出します
立花孝志は
70歳を超えても好奇心の
虜のような人でした
いつも
目をキラキラさせて
わからないから面白いんだよ
わかったらもっと面白いんだよ
面白いものは伝えたくなるし伝わったら
面白いじゃないのって
彼は言ってたんですねそして私はそのこと
に学生時代大変憧れてそういう大人になり
たいと思いました
今ここになって思うのは
形は違えども私は多分同じことをしている
んだと思います
それが
文章のアウトプットであるのか音楽の
アウトプットであるのかそれは結果の違い
であってやっぱり指揮者というのもここで
お話しするということも何かを書くという
ことも
それは自分が心震えるものを探しそして誰
かに伝えたいと思うという行為なんだと
思います
私がここで言えることそれは
強い共振を生みたければまず自分が震えて
いなければいけない
そして
孤独ということに向き合い
孤独から逃げずに
君でなければいけないのかという固有性の
問いに
答えられるようにあり続けること
そういうふうに思います
このセッションはですね
問うということがテーマになっていたと
思います
問うということがテーマだと一般的には
自分が問うた結果つまり何かの
プロジェクトであったり今まで自分がなし
たことであったりそういうことを話すこと
が
多いのかもしれませんが私はあえてここで
当そのあり方それ自体をここでお話しして
みたかった
皆さんにここで言いたかったことそして私
が
心情として思っているのは
君でなければいけないのかその問いである
この君でなければならないのかという問い
が
皆さんの中に今日じんわりと共振し何かの
次の問いにつながっていくことを願って
終わりとしたいと思いますありがとう
ございました
[拍手]